a nevada congresswoman hopes to make
changes to how wild horses are rounded
up and taken care of as 8 news now
i-team chief reporter george knapp first
reported nevada democrat dina titus
wants to put a stop to the use of
helicopters in rounding up horses and
that's not all now we want to warn you
some of this video can be hard to watch
[Music]
over hundreds of thousands of years the
first equines on earth roamed and
evolved in nevada's great basin in the
past century though their reintroduced
ancestors have been decimated dwindling
from millions of north american mustangs
to perhaps 70 000 today
typically bands of horses are surprised
and frightened by the loud machines that
suddenly appear in the sky often buzzing
within feet of the mustang's heads the
herds scatter and scramble across rough
terrain some are chased for miles others
suffer broken legs or injuries that mean
they must be put down during each
round-up blm releases statistics on the
number of forces killed the number
killed will depend on how many are
together but there's always loss of life
when the use of helicopters for around
always wild horse advocate jerry
reynoldson has spent decades trying to
get the blm to try something other than
rounding up the mustangs from public
lands often done in order to clear the
way for private cattle to graze on the
same range administrations come and go
but the blm policy of scooping up wild
horses never seems to change since the
70s that has meant helicopter roundups
that are brutally efficient around us
with helicopters are the worst nevada
congresswoman dina titus has worked on
measures to manage and protect the
mustangs since her days in the state
legislature but says this particular
image was the last straw for her it's a
cult trying to escape from a helicopter
despite a broken leg the horse had to be
euthanized as did others during this
nevada roundup last month they chased
that little culturally just ran down and
then they had to shoot them what purpose
does that serve so we need to find
another method and the first thing we
can do is get rid of outlaw ban those
helicopters on tuesday morning titus
spoke on the floor of the house in
support of her bill to eliminate
helicopter roundups of wild horses my
wild horse and burro protection act
would outlaw the use of helicopters and
titus thinks her bill will garner rare
bipartisan support not merely because of
the animal cruelty issues but because
helicopter roundups are incredibly
expensive costing the taxpayers 500 to
800 per captured horse meaning more than
40 million dollars have been paid to
fewer than five private contractors who
do the work after the surviving horses
are captured the expenses mount they get
shipped off to be warehoused for the
rest of their lives at ranches owned by
other contractors i'm not saying you
don't need to manage the wildlife on blm
land or forest land throughout nevada
including the horses but there's got to
be better ways to do it than
running them into a canyon with a
helicopter images like the one that
mobilized titus are harder to come by in
recent years blm makes sure that public
observers are kept far away from the
actual roundups jerry reynoldson is
among those who will support the titus
bill but predicts major opposition in
the senate because of the big money that
flows in a circle what we have here is a
big loop
we
we we gather the horses to help the
ranchers so they can have subsidized
crazy
we and and pay millions to run a program
that's a huge loser to the taxpayers and
then we turn around when we take them
off and pay them
millions and millions of dollars to hold
them for the rest of their life in a pan
george knapp 8 news now